citizens of the reject Nation you asked
and we deliver Tara Erickson is back on
the channel Round of Applause for you
Tara it's good to see you we're about to
watch Hotel Transylvania for the first
time and I am very excited I wrote this
movie off a little bit when it first
came out only to discover that it is a
Gandhi tartakovsky joint Big Love for
Dexter's Laboratory some beautiful
animation across like Samurai Jack and
Primal and all sorts of other stuff so
I'm actually quite excited now to check
this out but Tara how are you feeling
today I mean I'm excited to watch a
movie that I have never watched that I
also wrote off back in 2012. oh the end
of the world yeah yeah taking it back
we're about to get spooky but before we
do leave a like on this video and also
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
when you do that
[Music]
and don't forget to follow Tara over on
social media as well as La eat some
drinks which is your new food based
Endeavor no yeah it's great I have it on
YouTube and Instagram go give it a
follow give it a like you can also give
me a good old like on the YouTubes guys
the last thing I need to tell you before
we hop into this is to come check us out
over at patreon.com the real rejects
when you subscribe over there you can
check out the full length watch along of
Hotel Transylvania sync up with your own
copy see everything that doesn't make
these reaction highlights and uh without
further ado
let's do it
[Music]
cool
Castle Dracula ah Maybe
we'll see
[Music]
magic diaper change wow that would just
that would be a dream Parenthood seems
so much easier as a vampire yeah maybe a
little more square footage I want a lot
of monsters here oh we never go out
there
ever why not Parry the human found them
and jumped out from under their bed I'm
scared and burned their clothes and took
their candy oh you went too far I
promised your mommy I would protect you
forever
oh where's Mommy beautiful baby
let me wipe all your poop away
and if a human tries to harm you I'll
simply say
okay uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
just bend the legs and push off trust me
Mouse
oh
baby
[Music]
fast love the details in this room like
a doll in a cage and a pile of little
skulls skulls on the floor
two acres of Haunted Forest in front of
you you've got
you karimeters any humans daring to even
look over there we'll run away real
quick
I'd be like what up zomb yeah let's take
a picnic out in that graveyard
the place we always talked about for
Mavis
no one will ever harm her here
wow holy junk
that is a castle Dracula I would love to
live there and a Hotel Transylvania
[Music]
headless Carriage driver
oh cool
welcome to Hotel Transylvania
oh fun there is a clogged toilet in room
we all get stomach aches Mr Bigfoot
I'm gonna need a bigger plunger
Hey kid oh you're only supposed to make
Mom and Dad miserable this is Steve
Buscemi the family looks beautiful let
me just clean up their field
housekeeping
cool it's like The Wizard of Oz
oh
SpongeBob everything is alive buddy
what's going on with your Cape Town what
do you mean who pitched me you're
irresistible yeah it's very amusing
Invisible Man hello great to see you
you're looking skinny too now that
you're just a head okay you'll pay for
that
nope still not right you were right
about those directions oh good good yeah
I took the Tigers through the Nile and
there was absolutely no traffic
oh gnarly
oh I was not the cause of that Ah that's
CeeLo Green's voice
oh
and they know that a successful year of
Refuge from them these are recent human
images our surveillance has uncovered
they are getting fast
but they will never find us here evil
villain you will never win
said that when I when I turned 118 I
could go out into the world like every
other adult she looks great
and no reflection I like that you just
showed them like a snuff film in the
lobby before equivalently
not Disturbed do not disturb oh I want
one of those on my door for do not
disturb same you want to go out into the
world you can you gave me your word and
you know that I know that a Dracula's
word is sacred that our trust is the
core of our wait what I said you can go
oh uh holy rabies baby oh
not expecting that
I'm going to paradise and this is some
stuff that I thought I would need it's a
place out there where you and Mom
why won't you ever tell me about how you
met it's actually Hawaii how what what
but everyone has gone to Great Lanes to
come see you on your birthday I love
them but I really want to see new things
maybe meet somebody my age you're only
118.
you're just a child don't give me the
powdy bad face oh it's so cute there is
a humid Village just a little ways past
this Cemetery you could go there and be
back in like 30 minutes or so thanks for
trusting me of course my little one I
gave you my word oh
what have you washed it letting your own
daughter out there with those horrible
humans you always tell us about they
hate us they're vicious and they're very
loud
she's a Dracula for Pete's sake but
seriously watch out for fire fire bad
hi everybody why are there candles lit
on a carpet if fire is bad I know and
right above your head waiting to happen
I also love that the Bride of
Frankenstein looks like Frank and hooker
as well they gave her the frankenhooker
colored outfit like I wonder if that's
intentional
[Music]
find her a place with like a heavy goth
community and it'll be fine yeah
there's nobody there
is this like he built this and it's fake
and there's oh my no humans is there a
some one of the signs to carry and it
had pigs on it oh
uh hello anybody out there
no thank you my name is Mavis Dracula
and a vampire
are they close
oh they're like fake
it's like a model Village and these must
be like zombies in Disguise or something
yeah oh yeah yeah you called it we
called it we call it
please I've never heard anyone I'm
homeschooled is that garlic garlic bread
ow
oh boy I mean a human might do that
oh fire bad whoa hey you don't need a
mannequin
oh
but but Lars and the Real Girl oh
excellent sound stages
this is where they produce all their
films nice jobs
Backlot Transylvania
you're tall and they had garlic on bread
delicious
what did you do what I had to sure thank
me one day yeah that's what the guy who
shrunk my handset
the trader Sam two of his heads for one
of yours
someone her a
school
and how did you find this place oh I'm
Jonathan and I was just mountain
climbing with some dudes
a story about a spooky Forest
you're gonna go into a spooky Forest
right yeah
and it just kind of follows them to this
like amazing Castle
every white guy in a horror movie I feel
so represented if someone should see you
no one would ever come again
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's just a monster everybody stepped it
up tonight
hey sniffy what's going on not right now
Quasimodo Ratatouille hey
don't be upset he's not a human but mess
your Dracula how ridiculous it's me
Mario how are you pulling this off I
could just put my hand right through oh
I think you're doing oh no
keep your hands out of my wife oh dude
at the Hotel Transylvania pure chaos
[Music]
oh damn no
no that's a big giant spider for me nope
I don't know why I ever wanted to leave
the humans are so boring
no no not the pregnant lady oh
meet cute who is that nobody seriously
Dad Dad Dracula's daughter everyone
freaks out at first
[Music]
a place I built for all those monsters
out there lurking in the shadows a place
of peace relaxation and Tranquility cool
so it's like a hotel for Monsters it who
exactly is that I thought there would be
even more besties specialist if someone
closer to your age helped plan the party
how old are you 118. 100
.
okay you're not hanging out because you
are leaving
oh cool is that real about the garlic
thing yes I cannot have it my throat
swells oh it's too bad it's delicious
yeah well who wouldn't that kill
that's a great Point actually
stake in the heart yes I know it's your
honeymoon I apologize go go back to
doing what you were doing
what's happening it's my mistake what is
wrong with you
[Music]
the animation is really funny yeah like
I love the sort of cartoonier aspects
did you get to rehearse at all zombie
Beethoven
we even thought maybe you'd sing with us
you know that I haven't sung in public
since Martha yeah but we just thought
that how much you know Mavis would love
it I said no don't ask me again now
let's hug these zombies let's all make
up wow he really scared you I wasn't
scared I was being polite okay
[Laughter]
I'm not the Frankenstein I'm his cousin
Johnny Stein Johnny Stein hey Mavis
oh are these monsters gonna kill me not
as long as they think you're a monster
huh that's kind of racist
[Music]
is he making fun of me that's kind of
racist
the original owner of your arm had the
brother who married a woman who was hey
for strangling a pig I have pigs
shrinking blood in my arm that's cool
well cuz great to meet you
you all play let's check you guys out
huh
[Music]
Seems Like Only Yesterday you
use
[Music]
hold on guys
cue but kind of old school yes yeah
let's punk rock it up give me a jam
[Music]
I am so blown away right now cause is
gonna make this the best party ever yeah
[Music]
shut up that's the only kind of bingo I
ever want to play
bingo bingo oh I didn't do that the fly
pants
vomit
I'm tired just watching this yeah
that's a funny gag
er's got pop
do for another comeback
Taj Mahal come on no monsters been
just gotta roll he just rolls that's
cool that he rolls
so cool brought you a bagel with your
favorites delicious
oh scream cheese you would say you hurt
your back and you have to leave oh dudes
oh my back I love you back no no he said
oh my back
whoa
subscribe push him off
all his makeup's gonna come off
oh boy oh boy honey the Stein boys of
bread for this kind of thing Geronimo
[Music]
oh
my God
physical gags are very funny
yeah
uh-oh
oh no oh this is make oh wow oh God okay
you have no memory of this place or the
monsters who met now go and never return
but is JanSport return to the hotel what
I just use my powers to erase your
memory I looked straight into
oh maybe it's the contact lenses what
uh here let me just try and get him out
real quick
[Music]
oh God
scariest part of this movie or I will
track you down and suck every ounce of
blood from your body until you look like
a deflated whoopee cushion dad
I thought she was gonna show up yeah
same guess not follow me oh oh no no
Mavis I can't I have to leave you sure
it'll be fun okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
Tang
wow
you can almost see Budapest is that near
Wi-Fi a Wi-Fi you've been everywhere I'm
only gonna be uh 121 once right gotta
live it
yeah you said it
oh man so pretty the sunrise oh he's not
burning though oh come on I have an idea
oh watch
oh one said Johnny kid going to be done
party planning it was so nice seeing
Mavis laughing and hitting it off with
him Mavis could never be with someone of
his kind that's all right hello
this is the most incredible thing I've
ever seen
no he decided he didn't like Mavis or
any of us
go to a corner you're in the timeout I'm
out I'm a grown man
oh 16 to 47 1950
awesomeness just let me do my work
36 up
oh cool
oh where'd you go did you go to pop
don't freak out gravity face ah eat my
jet scraping 56 and 43 to my side
you go trick him into having fun yeah
keep smelling oh but it's a human and
then I will make human but
oh
he's having 45 65 76 48 Block is Hot
block is bad
wow that's gonna hurt if they're
oh come on now good man nice
yes
fun times
I got you buddy hey
frenzies oh you too you did it kid now
he's gonna have to protect you so you
don't become soup
that was fun uh oh is he hurt
nailed it
Johnny
uh what was Immortal
doing the anime run do you know
why do you want to know oh
do you like him what what it's like are
you an idiot or do you know you're
adorable
oh
I need them stopped immediately is that
clear yes squat we are on it
whoa what is that meaning of this let's
be passed quasimana Wilson
[Music]
why did that hurt
spider's just trying to kick it
wins again find your bump with the hump
your land on your head
bars bars
oh no damn it oh
he made it into the kitchen I'm sorry
honey I I have the eyes follow you if he
is a monster let them scares Esmerelda
[Music]
oh no
it's too much I know her there's a whole
legend around that lady the story is
that a lonely count met her by chance
and they say that no two Souls were ever
more meant for each other oh a horrible
tragedy happened a fire started
mysteriously one night and it killed
both of them oh sad beautiful animation
it was only
the wife that died
oh
I love her little
Broach thing
she was killed by your kind
vampire
Martha
oh Mavis has feelings for you what I I
just
awesome
that was so cute
you'd make a great vampire because I
think I kind of got your hypnosis let me
see it be well for you are in my power
the werewolf man
yes
oh my God
I have a lot of kids too many oh
oh
[Music]
I didn't order a wake-up call
there would be no snoozing the parties
today
oh I feel so bad for him
oh
change of fashion
[Music]
get that Cape yeah girl
oh the gifts What's it gonna be I can't
believe
[Music]
oh yeah
spooky auto tune
oh dang looking good in that Cape girl
that's a glow up
wow
jeez
Paris Broadway New York Moscow
Aloha
it's amazing
oh trust Falls whoa now do the Wednesday
Adam's dance
oh no falling in love
yeah okay
got the moves he knows how to have fun
now I'm crazily scared right now maybe
that's a good thing
[Music]
oh
maybe I want to give the village another
chance I just need to learn you know
just that won't make a difference how do
you toss it just won't why won't it that
Village doesn't really exist
the base he says Dracula has brought a
human into the hotel
there is the human he has a French
accent
oh no get off me [__] you
I don't believe
no no
are you a human are you in frankface yes
I'm so sorry she's gonna be okay with it
yeah I don't care oh I still want to be
with you oh
turn him I don't want to be with you
because you're a monster and I hate
monsters
no
this is all your fault whoa oh
you're the real monster yeah man Mavis
you're doing me a favor will you erase
my mind oh
there are so many eligible monsters out
there you're so young
what is it what are you reading
oh I said her gifts
[Music]
too lonely
lonely they felt a Zing love at first
sight
your Zing will come my love cherish it
love mommy
mummy I thought we zinged dad but you
should be happy dad there's no reason
for me to leave
I have no more dreams oh I'm just like
you now oh
ouch tell her the truth Dad it's your
fault yeah
Martha what have I done why did you say
that name
you messed up man please stop it's too
late I need you to help me find Johnny
the human
he touched my guitar oh the truth is I
don't even know if humans are bad
anymore first you tell us humans are bad
now they're good what else Up Is Down
Colter's hat Gremlins don't smell hey
hey I think they sing
but I got in the way
you only sing once
well what are we doing let's get Johnny
come on
a happy mob where am I going the human
world before Johnny is gone forever but
what about the Sun
I don't know I'll just have to roll haha
it was the classic Universal Monster
game my sniffing tracking days are way
behind me do you know how many diapers
and I've changed how many number twos
have destroyed this thing oh
he's got an army now
what do you blow the wolf whistle Winnie
front Dance Center
oh
she's so cute I can't stand it
it's 8 A.M departure that's in 15
minutes oh man 23
I'm a vegetarian okay thank you cutie I
love her good job Winnie
I got this one
oh wow whoa wow okay that was pretty
sick man you eat lamb chops it's the
same thing
jeez I'm gonna save some of the wool oh
it's a monster Festival
surprise Jack's okay in the sunlight
that's how you blend in perfect do you
know the best way to the airport yes
fellow Dracula there's only one way blah
blah blah
but the only way they know the real us
is if we show the real us
I got nothing oh whoa
[Applause]
oh
yay
what a wonderful performance nice pipes
Tamika
[Music]
real Dracula prove it
this is how we prove all humans are good
clear a path for the man protect our
friends
so
we did it very clever it's great
[Music]
oh hapula
that is a lot of Draculas is Dracula the
Joker of the monster convention
oh he's so sad
oh you're gonna burn
we're gonna get it
oh god
oh man
okay I must do this
[Music]
poor Wings come on
oh
fire
[Music]
Twilight Dracula
what my hands in a tan shoe what pans
eating lamb stew
[Music]
well we hear a special announcement for
my dear friend I have made a terrible
mistake you and Mavis are meant to be
using I hope you can hear me and forgive
me
you too cute okay folks we are going to
make a quick turnaround to refuel and
then we'll be back on our way
he made a big sacrifice
you know Mommy already gave you her
birthday present can I now give you mine
what do I need this for oh it comes with
an accessory
why are you back cause you're my zing
Mavis
you told me you hate monsters I was
afraid your dad was gonna suck all the
blood out of my body if I didn't say
that hey no he's right I would have done
that yeah
can we try that kiss over again I think
we can
sorry just a habit I I just I got to get
used to that that just go go do your
thing yeah get out of here Dad
oh so cute I thought I found a love but
she was just a fling and then I had a
girl built a different thing yes
[Music]
cute oh come on just give it a try all
right maybe just a little bit
get ready bars
the only
thing whoa whoa oh boy
on a flying table
uh
well done
hip Tunes
of 2012.
I love that they took the time to do a
little 2D for the credits here really
bring some of those Gandhi tartakovsky
vibes
yes
I like when Adam Sandler plays like a
full-on character I thought it was
Selena Gomez damn it I should have
called it
I really like I like this song
get that download
Kevin James okay Steve Buscemi Molly
Shannon
[Music]
well his friend Drescher was Miss
Frankenstein Shirley
I'm sorry for I mean can't get all of
them
laughs
foreign
Catherine apple is a an adorable name
absolutely
I didn't do that
[Music]
I love it
yes
oh
that was delightful it was fun
what did you think Tara Erickson I liked
it I had fun I thought that
I liked how they got to the heart more
towards the end I wanted more a little
bit of that heart up top so that I cared
uh just slightly more me I think would
have made that moment between him and
the kid when he shows the kid the girl's
mother mavis's mother I thought it would
have made it more impactful there's
something about it where I was like I
wanted a little more heart at top to get
to uh to get to that part between him
and the kid but overall uh it was a lot
of fun the animation was hilarious a lot
of the physical gags were made on top of
the punchline jokes it's it's really
like a lot of Comedy the entire time I
felt like like everything if you looked
around there's a punchline either
physical or verbally which I'm like yeah
it's a bit it's a comedy it's great yeah
yeah I I can I can I can I I get why
they position things the way they did
however I could see yeah like even
starting the movie off with a prologue
or something that talks about or that
that sort of shows what happened to you
know Dracula and his love or or
something like that yeah but um I do
agree like I I in the age of
you know the expansion of animated
movies and things like that and then
like a post Pixar world I've come to
sort of appreciate
you know the tradition of slightly
zanier animated fair you know not that
that's what I want everything to be and
I certainly love when you have like a
Pixar thing that's trying to get all
deep and stuff but I do also just
appreciate the tradition of you know
classic comedic animation and you know
coming from somebody like Gandhi
tartakovsky who has a lot of experience
especially in like 2D stuff I did really
appreciate like like you pointed out all
that physicality to go along with the
written jokes because there's so much
like squash and stretch and like big
poses and and yeah just like really
Punchy and quirky physical animation
that I thought you know Harkens to you
know a lot of those more 2D styles of
Animation but was well suited to this so
yeah it's like even though it certainly
starts out in the light and fun
territory and then eventually develops
it's hard over time I was always kind of
enticed by whatever was going on whether
it be just the fun stuff or whether it
be like I got a little misty-eyed you
know during some of the more emotional
beats later on
um and I just you know as as someone who
like loves horror and monster movies and
stuff like there's just so many little
fun details and and the way they realize
just the world and this Society of
monsters I thought was really Charming
yeah the editing was amazing especially
when they're cutting back and forth in
in the very beginning of setting it up
of like Hotel Transylvania when you see
all the monsters you're introduced to
those characters and how they're all
moving about the world but very quickly
I I really thought that that was like
very good yeah yeah and a great like a
great array of voices too I thought
because I mean you know you're in an
Adam Sandler joint so you're gonna have
a bunch of Sandler's friends on the
voice cast yeah uh but I thought it
worked you know because because I one
thing I know that kind of dogs some
animation is is people get kind of
frustrated with like you cast just these
big names when you could be cast lasting
real voice actors who are well suited to
animation but here I thought I mean
everybody was well cast for the most
part and certain people you know you
could tell but other people you know
were kind of more in character in a way
that you might not have expected so much
so like I I always prefer Adam Sandler
when he's committed to a character of
some kind
um so yeah like having him you know at
least committed to this accent and this
Dracula Vibe you know was a nice you
know sort of departure for me granted
I'm not seeing him on screen but you
know it's just like a a nice you know
commitment to the character I thought
yeah I also was like uh it's a little
outdated with like her that The Zing
like she needs to get married and like
have a have a man I'm like this is
outdated but it was still very cute
um I also think obviously yes there are
people who you're still gonna have a
zing and people are getting married
still all over the world yeah it's just
that that it's it's it's an old school
aspect effect yeah um versus it's simple
yeah it's it's very it's simple where
I'm like oh it would have been uh maybe
not that they would
like uh I wish I kind of wish that there
would have been something said that yes
they had a Zing but it's like
um The Zing might not last forever like
no pressure why don't we just like
travel and be buddies and see how it
goes yeah you know what I mean but that
would that would have been too much I
think it's adorable the way it is it's
just yes it's a little it seemed a
little like uh okay yeah toward a more
modern sensibility you go like okay like
you know it's a certain perspective that
you you only have your one zing and this
is the thing and yeah like I don't
necessarily begrudge at that but also I
think yeah like a more uh interesting
choice could have just been like no you
know what you should go out and
experience the world you know you've
grown up enough to know how to take care
of yourself a little bit and yes follow
this romance certainly yeah but you
never know what
little don't you know put all your eggs
into the one basket yeah yeah yeah like
sort of if if you're teaching if you're
trying to share a a thing here with
Children of the same age it's sort of
like go out explore but you don't have
to like commit to this one zingy dude
yes especially because like you know
he's and I wonder if I don't know in the
sequels maybe they'll turn him or
something or what but you know it's like
she's 118 and he's like 21 or something
like he's you know like a young adult uh
and so you know you also have those
questions about like you know so much
time time yeah what's what was he gonna
he's gonna have to turn if they're gonna
spend their whole lives together
um but I liked his character and I liked
uh he's so funny like I'd forgotten to I
you know I'd seen the trailer for this
ages ago but I'd forgotten uh that
entire aspect of the trailer I just
remembered like yeah it's Dracula hotel
for Monsters and uh and he's got a
daughter and so like at the outset of
the movie I was like okay it's gonna be
about him learning to let go
um but you know and it's it's a classic
you know animation Trope but I liked
yeah the Andy Samberg character coming
in and teaching everybody how to loosen
up a little bit have a little fun and I
like this stuff about you know like how
monsters view the humans and how humans
view the monsters and like certainly it
is a lucky thing that they happened upon
a monster Festival where people were
inclined to be excited I was a little
like all right yeah um but again it's
like it's an animated movie it's it's a
family movie certainly uh so I don't
begrudge at that and like you know any
of those choices that like could have
been more rich or more interesting at
least always led to again fun bits fun
gags little comic stripy things that
again took me back to yeah just just
sort of like the the classic animation
that you know is a bit slapsticky and
and you know funny and fun
um and yeah like you know coming out of
something like a Dexter's Laboratory way
back in the day it's like I liked seeing
some of those traditions in a 3D
animated format where yeah it's like you
have the crazy physicality and uh the
mannerisms and all that stuff again like
the squash and stretchiness and just
like the yeah the they're really good at
that Punchy physical comedy yeah
there was a lot of
a lot of tropes in this because like I
was even gonna say from the very
beginning the forest looks like Beauty
and the Beast because she's like run it
looks just like that and then
um yeah it's very much like they come
with pitchforks on fire to kill the
Beast
um which I'm like whatever yes it makes
sense like that that's what people do to
kill monsters but it gave me sort of a
little bit of that Vibe yeah Beauty and
the Beast Vibes which uh I love Beauty
and the Beast it's great it's one of the
best yeah one of the best Disney's
animated yeah
um and the songs in this were fun they
were good I liked when there was when
they were singing I was like Good Times
yeah I can I I I
it depends it's a case by case I could
take or leave uh you know like the the
in this kind of movie this sort of like
dance party number and we gotta make the
characters rap right and I think not the
ending the oh but the beginning sure but
yeah I guess I mean not to begrudge that
song either like it's appropriate it
fits like I I don't think it's it's bad
per se but I do it's funny that like and
Andy Samberg should have should go on
later to do the Chippendale movie where
they'd literally call out the whole
thing about like animated characters
have to rap
um and you know like it was fine like
I've heard cringier versions of that and
I also thought it was funny that like
CeeLo Green is a singer and they
auto-tuned the [__] out of his voice
sorry why because he's great yeah and
said he's known for those pipes and like
they let Selena Gomez sing a little bit
and and when she started singing that
was when I the whole time I was sitting
there going I bet her but when she
started singing I was like okay must be
like that probably is part of why they
hired her but you know even there you
get a little bit of a Lonely Island Song
and that helps it for me a little bit oh
yeah because you know I feel like there
is an inroad there where it's not just
like oh we're trying to make a cool pop
song for the end of this movie for the
kids and you know something to play on
Radio Disney or whatever uh you know
it's having that Association for me from
my perspective as an adult viewer is
like okay cool it's like The Lego Movie
has a Lonely Island tune in it so like
having I guess what I'm trying to say is
having that comedic element to the song
Just knowing Annie's Andy samberg's
rapping adds to the lightness of it yeah
um but the earlier bits yeah it's like
when they're practicing to play the
actual birthday party yeah they do their
dreary song sounded like great it
sounded perfectly like detuned and sort
of like flattened but not bad and then
he picks up the guitar and like really
breathes some life into it and I thought
that was like a musical gag that had a
nice disposition about it yeah because I
feel like in the musicals that I've seen
that I've liked they all sound real it's
not like auto-tune there's nothing on
top of it it's it's more real voices but
it it is funny to me of what you said
like CeeLo Green Selena Gomez they can
like actually really sing that I'm like
oh they could really utilize that a lot
more yeah and I thought it was that Adam
Sandler they would let him see like I
again yeah the rap is fun like the bars
are are again I've heard worse bars and
movies like this but I'm like Adam
Sandler is partly known for musical
comedy so I was thinking like oh he's
gonna have some kind of like funds
Dracula style number or show stopper or
or even just one of his you know guitar
songs or something like that right you
know not that it like needs that like
the priority of this isn't to you know
be an Adam Sandler joint first and
foremost you know it's like I think a
lot of kids watching it probably
wouldn't be even aware of that but you
know yeah I thought it was interesting
and it is one of the more odd and the
more sort of like markety elements of
the movie I guess to me is is yeah it's
like the the you know show stop and
musical numbers have that sort of like
hyper polish on them
um but you know again not like
inappropriate not like you know uh turn
this off or something like that you know
yeah no just was just like it's really
polished yeah a little bit yeah in some
in some of the cases but I liked how
they used the lore I love the
personality of the hotel and the just
characterization of all the different
creatures and all the fun uh again like
little voices and stuff popping up but
yeah that's like I would gladly continue
on if anybody cares about you know
watching the sequels uh this was this
was certainly
you know like like we set up at the top
we both were kind of like ah you know
Adam Sandler anime I'm sure it'll be
fine but I was like quite delighted like
not maybe 100 perfect but for the most
part I came out of this with like a
really sort of joyous fun feeling yeah
it hit all the it hit all the important
boxes with gusto for me so anything that
I might gripe about is like not that big
a deal in my viewing experience anyway
yeah mine either I thought it was a lot
of fun I liked the jokes in it and the
characters like especially in uh what's
the kid's name with the what's his name
oh my God
you did this what is his name with the
red hair oh it was his name actually
Johnny I called him Johnny Frank it's
Johnny Stein yeah it was like what is
his action whatever we'll just call him
Johnny sign I'm like what I don't know
what his name was but I liked the
um the juxtaposition between him and all
of the other characters and him just
sort of being a deadpan teen which uh
May made a lot of those jokes that come
from all of those animated characters
and all those crazy voices made him he's
not a little bit of the straight man to
bounce off of and with his like deadpan
Emma's like it there was a sort of
relief in there which I really enjoyed
sure sure yeah I liked that yeah and I
mean like I I I'm always delighted for a
surprise Andy Samberg and like you know
I I like that uh that they that he and
Sandler have become buds but yeah like
you know because he's one of those guys
too where he brings his sandbergginess
but also perfect for this kind of
character oh yeah you know he's got that
thing you know he plays up that like you
know kind of bro-ish like young dude
intonation and and uh and just yeah like
his Plucky enthusiasm and then actually
having him freak out I thought was a
good call instead of making him just
immune to everything it's like at first
he shows up and he thinks like oh cool
this is fun this is you know a nice gag
and then he realized everything's real
and like I'm glad that they had at least
that debate eight and then you know
little asides to again tolerance and
things like that through this character
yeah and whatever else but uh yeah man I
had a blast I had fun fun times fun
times we did it again man for joining me
Tara I'm glad that we got to share this
it seemed like like a good uh uh vehicle
because we're always searching when
after after searching after uh Last of
Us people were like we need more Tara
yeah so uh yeah so now I'm back yeah
you're gonna get so sick of it it's
gonna be nothing but Tara get her out of
here in fact we're just gonna shoot
still gonna be here that's right we're
gonna shoot your reaction twice splice
it together so it's like you watching
with yourself with myself yeah and then
and then release it four times a week
definitely yeah I love that love that
for me honestly I do too yeah I mean if
you guys get tired of it I don't care no
never guys do not care I don't care what
you're tired of but what I do care about
is what you thought about this movie did
you grow up with this did you love this
do you how what are your thoughts what
are your feelings what other animated
Fair would you like to see us check out
if we haven't seen it already what's
your favorite Genie tartakovsky joint
he's got a new show out I'm excited to
see unicorn Warriors Eternal and I'm
glad that he's had just uh you know is
getting his flowers these days you know
he seems like he's finally he's been
prolific for so long and uh and yeah I'm
just glad to you know that people are
learning his name in the recognition
exactly so like subscribe all that good
stuff keep an eye out on the channel for
the next reaction and hey before we get
out of here let's do a little patron of
the day shout out let's do it
Mark Leach Mark I chose you because out
of everyone remaining for the month of
May shout outs you have perhaps the
spookiest implication with your name
last name but also a misunderstood
implication because leeches get a bad
rap my friend but they're part of our
ecosystem they're not monsters they have
many practical applications and they're
alive they've got hopes and aspirations
they want to see the world but they're
afraid because we uh you know we don't
like them you know which is only China I
don't really
I don't want to hang out with them I
don't really want them to leech and like
suck my blood even if I was like dying I
might be like I feel like can we find
anything else besides a leech see and
see so you could be the pr like dream
come true for the leech Community
because you are the perfect intersection
you're a human person but you can also
commune with both sides and maybe
Enlighten us make us more tolerant of
leech kind and then maybe in Hotel
Transylvania 2 there will be like a
whole leech subplot yeah we didn't see
any leeches no no one and that's
unfortunate spiders and yeah
category sure sure they would be like
you know they got like a pond or
something out there that they were all
swimming in or like a pool you could
have so many leaves they have piranhas
where's the leeches yeah exactly get on
that man get on it Mark insert yourself
yeah come on now and stay pledged and uh
and keep being the opposite of a leech
in our lives and uh hey
but I said a different thing that's okay
that's okay I was gonna say like do
people make this like how many leech
jokes do you have to bear as a human you
know my name my last name Humphrey you
get a lot of jokes throughout your life
that people think are original but then
they're absolutely not original that's
why you just don't ever make the joke
when it's obvious you just don't even
you just don't even do it like for
Humphrey I would never mention his last
name ever for leech I wouldn't do it
either except for here no we should redo
this shout out actually we should redo
the whole thing I'm so sorry Mark
because we messed up on the jokes right
that's why you're saying that because we
didn't do enough we didn't do anything
yeah okay got it got it well
it is what it is that's supposed to be a
joke Tara oh sorry Mark you know what
June we're gonna get it right love you
buddy stay pledged bye
foreign